okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
and i think we've had a
form out there for people to submit
questions and topics you'd like me to
try and talk about
and i see there are a few things that
have come in there
uh
all right there's one from stuart here
suggesting spatum as a portmanteau of
space atom atom of space
well i haven't heard that term before so
that's a new one on me i think this term
atoms of space is one that we've started
to use in connection with our physics
project maybe i should explain a little
bit
what we mean by atoms of space and what
kind of the story behind that is
you know i think i've talked about this
a few times before but but
my understanding of these things
gradually progresses as our physics
project has moved forward and for those
who don't know
uh the kind of the the current
the traditional sort of leading theories
in physics
date from about 100 years ago
the general relativity is the theory of
gravity and quantum mechanics and
quantum field theory as the theory of
very small things
and
in
the last couple of years
much to my surprise in many ways things
that i've been kind of working towards
for several decades have kind of
converged to the point where it looks
like we have a serious other step in
understanding kind of the low-level
structure of our universe it's very
exciting
but kind of the place that starts is a
better understanding of space
and by space i mean the the thing that
exists everywhere in the universe that
we move around in the thing that has you
know three dimensions roughly that uh
that we can move in
and
the thing that uh people have kind of
assumed about space for basically two
thousand years
is
that
space is just sort of a background and
things get put in space wherever you
feel like putting something you can put
it there
and that there's no substructure into
space space is just like the blank sheet
of paper where you get to place points
wherever you want
okay so one of the sort of
uh
first things to realize in our project
is the idea that space isn't
actually just this background where you
can put things anywhere you want
space actually has its own internal
structure and kind of a good analogy for
this is a fluid like water
you might think that you know you pour
some water
it's just a continuous fluid it just
pours continuously and so on but in fact
for the last 150 years we've known that
water consists of discrete molecules and
if you kind of look sort of a fine
enough level under a powerful enough
microscope you'll basically be able to
see water is not just a continuous fluid
where you can sort of put something
anywhere you want in it it's made of
discrete molecules
that's something that have been kind of
people had wondered back in you know
ancient greek times and so on a couple
thousand years ago people had wondered
you know is the world actually made of
atoms as they called them atom means a
thing you can't split the greek for for
that and so it's sort of a thomas i
guess um not splittable um
and so of course it was a big deal in uh
in the
1930s and 40s and so on when it became
clear that one could actually split what
we thought of as atoms of material stuff
like hydrogen atoms or well that's not
one you can you can split but uh you
know uranium atom or something like this
that those were splittable those are
those are atoms of material objects
those are atoms of matter
um the question is are there discrete
atoms that make up everything that make
up space
that exists everywhere in the universe
or is that something that's just this
continuous background so to speak
so
the the thing that is sort of the
foundation of our physics project
is the idea that no there actually are
atoms of space
what are they like
well the only thing you can say about
them is they're kind of discrete
elements
they they're like uh each one you could
think of as being you you could uh you
could give it a name you could number it
you could do whatever you want but the
only thing you know about it is that
it's distinct from other ones
and then the only thing that is
determined about these things is how
they're related to each other so it's as
if every atom of space
is like a person and they're connected
in a friend network and all you know is
that friend network you don't know for
example there's no notion of what
position is this atom of space at what
position is that one at because there is
no space to put these things in it's
just this network of
sort of disembodied atoms of space
that are related by these connections
and so you can draw this big graph where
your big network where you have points
and you have connections between those
points that's kind of the structure that
represents space on a very very small
scale we don't know exactly how small
the scale is we think it might be a
trillion trillion trillion trillion
trillion trillion
trillion
trillionths
of a meter
so quite small uh and by the way
in in um
uh the the smallest we've ever been able
to probe with particle accelerators
which are kind of the analogue of our
most powerful microscope so they don't
look much like microscopes they're
they're things that accelerate particles
to high energy um and crash them into
other particles and see what happens but
the the kind of the the smallest scale
that one's been able to reach that one's
been able to probe with those is a one a
trillion trillionth of a meter
whereas what we're thinking the actual
scale of uh sort of
of the discreteness of space is charlie
challenging
many times of meter so much smaller than
that
so
the thing that um
uh so sort of the starting point is this
idea that what's at the lowest level in
our universe
is just this giant network of atoms of
space
and
i was sort of reluctant at the beginning
to pull them out into space because i
thought people would get confused with
atoms of matter which are things
actually made of protons and neutrons
and electrons and things like that what
we're talking about is the very lowest
level stuff of the universe the
fundamental thing that space is made out
of and one of the things that is sort of
more extreme in our model of physics
um is that actually everything is just
made of space
that the only thing that exists in the
universe is space it's kind of like if
you have a fluid like water you can have
a little vortex where you have water
circulating around and that vortex can
have a certain persistence it can move
through the water and so on and that's
what we think particles like electrons
and so on are really like they're kind
of like little persistent structures
within this network that represents uh
the structure of space
and
so sort of everything in our universe is
just made of space it's just all
features of this network that represent
space
and one of the things that then happens
is the kind of the progress of time
is kind of the progressive rewriting of
this network so there are rules that
basically say if there's a little local
piece of network that looks like this it
should be rewritten to one that looks
like that and those things are happening
trillions and trillions and trillions of
times every second every piece of space
is getting progressively rewritten and
to say that there's a particle is to say
there's some structure like the vortex
in the water even though the molecules
the water are bouncing around uh at a
small scale all over the place this
vortex is still surviving in the water
and it still persists for a long time
in time a very very long time relative
to the time it takes the molecules to
collide around in the water
so
the um the thing that actually something
i've been working on a bit recently
is one of the things that's really
surprising about things that happen in
the universe is that pure motion is
possible
that is it is not obvious if if
everything is made out of these atoms of
space and all these details of the
detailed connections of atoms of space
it's it's not obvious that that anything
that
is that that you could take this thing
that's made out of all these detailed
connections and just expect it to be
moved to a different place and stay more
or less the same
because in our theory basically whenever
i move the atoms of space that make up
me
are new different atoms of space
so it's not obvious that something that
is that corresponds to me so to speak
can be can exist at that new place and a
new position now i should just say that
one of the big features of our models is
that when you when you look at the
smaller scale all you see is atoms of
space and all sorts of detailed
rewriting of connections between atoms
and space and so on but if you zoom out
you know trillions and trillions of
times you will what you will see is
something that seems like ordinary space
as we experience it it's very much like
what happens in something like water if
you zoom all the way and you see a bunch
of molecules bouncing around if you zoom
out you see just a continuous fluid
that's flowing like like water does and
so it is with space
and most of the activity of space in our
universe in our theory consists in kind
of the rewriting of these detailed
patterns of connections between atoms of
space
in fact the the huge vast majority
you know
the the the amount of activity the
universe the amount of effort the
universe puts into rewriting the the
structure of of this network rewriting
these things at the level of atoms of
space is trillions and trillions of
trillions of times larger than
everything that is relevant to anything
we see about particles and and motion
and all those kinds of things most of
the activity of the universe is
maintaining the structure of space
and the things that happen within space
are just tiny little details on top of
this big activity of maintaining the
structure of space
so for example in the case of motion
what we're saying is there's this big
activity of maintaining the structure of
space and we can have a thing that
exists sort of on top of all that
activity that can be just moved from one
place in the universe one place in space
to another and can wind up being the
same kind of thing
and it is extremely non-trivial that
that's possible and it's something that
is deeply wound up i think with
questions about how we as observers of
the universe operate and the fact that
our consciousness is sort of based on
the idea that we think that there's sort
of a continuous thread of time that we
exist on and so on all of these things
are mixed together to lead to this
possibility of pure motion
and
by pure motion i mean you move something
around in space it doesn't change much
it doesn't change perceptibly now one of
the things that happens is
in in our models as in the traditional
theory of gravity space there's
curvature in space which means when your
gravitational field consists of a
distortion of the structure of space
and so when you're near a massive object
it generates gravity it distorts the
structure of space if you're near a
black hole it distorts the structure of
space a lot
and in fact if you're very near a
space-time singularity of the kind that
exists at the center of black hole you
distort space infinitely and when you
get to a place like that pure motion is
no longer possible if you take a thing
like a spacecraft or one of us or
whatever and you
are near a space-time singularity and
there isn't a space-time singularity for
a long way around us right now i don't
know where the nearest one is it might
be that's an interesting question
actually where the nearest black hole is
but it's certainly
maybe 500 light years away something
like that maybe more i'm not sure
um but it's not uh
you have to go a long way out
none of the nearby stars seem to be uh
black holes uh you have to you have to
go a long way out to get one so we're
not we're not in danger of this
happening to us any time uh around here
but in any case the um nearest
space-time singularity if you kind of go
near that space-time singularity the
structure of space
sort of disintegrates there and
there is no possibility of pure motion
any object is completely shredded as it
goes past that singularity
so that that's kind of the um so this
notion of atoms of space
is uh
is the thing that underlies this whole
set of ideas uh that leads the structure
of space and so on and one of the things
that's really kind of exciting is just
as when you study something like water
or air
there's a certain
way in which
you can make a model for how all these
molecules bounce off each other um and
sort of collide at a small scale but
when you when you zoom out to a large
scale you find out that there are
certain overall laws that are true about
gases overall laws that show about the
flow of fluids and you can derive those
independent of the details of how these
microscopic molecules work
well that derivation of the fluid
equations for example from microscopic
molecules the analog of that in our
model of space with atoms of space and
so on the analog of doing that leads you
to sort of a collective continuum
equation for how space behaves
and it turns out the equations you get
are exactly the equations that einstein
proposed in 1915 to be the equations
that describe the structure of
space-time so in other words from that
underlying structure of just talking
about atoms of space and connections
between atoms of space and so on when
you zoom out to a large scale you
discover that you get exactly gravity in
the way that we observe gravity to work
in our actual universe and that was the
core of the theory of generality back in
1915. so that's a pretty cool thing and
it's certainly something which back in
30 years ago made me think maybe maybe i
was sort of vaguely on the right track i
figured that out maybe i was sort of on
the right track in figuring out what's
kind of ultimately underneath
the the physics that we see today
now one of the things uh there's a lot
more to say about our physics theory let
me not go into that in detail here um
but
i will say in terms of this whole atoms
of of space thing
this whole notion of this underlying
structure of these abstract things that
are connected in this graph and are
updated and so on and they're updated in
many possible ways that's a whole other
story that leads to quantum mechanics
and so on
the um that whole story of sort of all
these different kinds of updatings of
all these uh these kind of abstract
elements
that story turns out to have a much more
general version that we figured out i
figured out um
fairly recently uh that leads to this
thing we call the ruliad
ruliad is a very strange creature the
ruliad is a very ultimate creature in
some ways i shouldn't say creature it's
an abstract kind of thing
um but
here's how you think about it
you think about
a
some rule that you might use that you
can just follow the rule you apply it
again again again it's like what how a
computer works you can think about it as
being that rule the application of that
rule as being a computation because it's
just like your computer it's just
applying these instructions applying
them again applying them again applying
them again to do what the computer does
but now imagine that you start off all
possible computers
from all possible initial conditions and
you just let them all run
well one of the things that will happen
is two computers that may be different
computers with different initial
conditions it will turn out that they
will uh at some point they will they
will end up
just evolving to the exact same state
just because
that that's uh that's what can happen
and so you get this giant sort of
entangled graph
of all possible computers evolving from
all possible states for an infinite
amount of time that's a giant entangled
thing and that's this thing i call the
ruliad
and
that thing
sort of represents
all possible computations it represents
in a sense all possible formal processes
and
the thing that is sort of exciting is
that what we've kind of realized is that
the way that
we
observe the universe
is
essentially by taking we we exist
we're sort of sensing some slice of this
giant roulead of uh of possible
computations
and
the particular slice we take depends on
how
it depends on us it depends on the fact
that you know we have certain sensory
systems and eyes that can sort of form
images and we have uh minds that kind of
think that we have persistence through
time and so on
those features
force us into sampling the rouliad in
such a way that we observe physics of
the kind that that
we we actually
know to be correct from sort of
observations experiments in physics
so one of the surprising and very
abstract things
is that when we do mathematics
we're actually also sampling the same
ruliad but in a slightly different way
so it's like there are physical
observers where we experience the
physical world and when we do abstract
mathematics pure mathematics and so on
we are essentially sampling
the um uh the same ruliad of all
possible computations but we're sampling
it in a different way but one of the
things that i've recently been studying
quite a lot
is we we as observers of the ruliad have
certain
limitations for example we can't do an
arbitrarily complicated computation we
we are bounded in the computations we
can do we believe we're persistent
through time for example these are
essentially limitations to the way we
observe the rulia
those limitations sort of affect us as
physical observers but they also affect
us as mathematical observers
and
that
that limitation those limitations of a
mathematical observer lead to certain
consequences for mathematics in fact one
of the things that i think is true
is the very fact that it is possible to
do higher level mathematics that's
possible to invent abstract mathematical
structures and have them be meaningful
is happens for essentially the same
reason as we can imagine that there is
this notion of continuous space that
we're not always thrown down into this
lowest level of looking at individual
atoms of space and so on and so
the thing that
one realizes is that sort of mathematics
the possibility of doing higher
mathematics
and having sort of mathematical
structures of being able to talk about
mathematical curves and things like this
not having to discuss mathematics down
at the level of its kind of lowest level
axioms and so on that possibility comes
from exactly the same place as the
possibility of doing higher level
physics and the possibility of thinking
about the universe in terms of things
like space and particles and so on and
not in terms of of low-level atoms of
space
so this is sort of a recent thing that
i've just about to actually
put out a big tone that i've been
writing a couple hundred pages long
about the physicalization of meta
mathematics which is kind of the this
story of how there's sort of a physical
interpretation
of what happens in the structure of
mathematics
but um that means that the these atoms
of space that we talk about as being the
lowest level things that make up the
physical universe there is a direct
analog of those in mathematics
and it's actually they're the same thing
they're both elements of this rule you
had and the name we're using is eems
e-m-e-s
it's kind of a
a a
sort of a colorless kind of um uh
uh word that means like a phoneme or a
or a or a uh
morpheme lots of other kind of things
mean elements of things this is sort of
a pure element of anything
so one of the most bizarre ideas
is uh which i'm not sure and it'll be
able to explain great but um uh the
question might be
what's the analog if i say an electron
is this kind of persistent structure
that exists in the low-level structure
of space
then what's kind of the analog of that
in these other in for example the ruliad
in general and one of the most bizarre
ideas recent idea is the following thing
so
we can think of
different places in this roulette
as
you think of different places in
ordinary space as just we know what that
means they're just different positions
in space
but
and we can get between those positions
in space by by moving by this idea of
motion in space
different positions in the rouliad are
also possible
and to get from one to the other we
essentially have to translate from one
form of computation from one way of
computing things to another way of
computing things so different positions
in the roulead in a sense correspond to
different interpretations of what's
going on different forms of computation
and i think that's very much like what
happens between different people for
example we all have some view of the
world and we have some representation of
everything
and somebody else will have a somewhat
different view of the world and
representation of everything and somehow
we can communicate between these
something persistent a little bit like a
particle is able to get from one mind to
another so to speak
and what are those things that sort of
are are persistent and packageable and
don't depend on the specifics of an
individual mind and essentially those
are things like words and concepts that
we manage to kind of package up and we
say a word
like uh like motion for example
and the the sender of that word might
have some representation in their brain
for what that word means the receiver
might have some completely different
representation but we've kind of got
this transport level of that just the
word which we can kind of communicate
from one person to another and so the
the very bizarre kind of uh you know
could this possibly be true
thing that sort of at the at the outer
limits of what i'm thinking about right
now is this possibility that concepts
the notion of discrete concepts and
words for concepts and so on is related
to the existence of discrete particles
in physics so that's about as as far out
as it gets in terms of
of sort of relations between different
areas
all right so many um
many other questions we have here
uh
um
let's see
um
well
let's try a few others here gosh there's
so many interesting questions you guys
are asking
this is um
i'm um
well let's see
all right there's a question here
um
i wanna do this this is more a
historical question about whether i have
a masterpiece or vladimir arnold yes i
yes i have um
what do i think of the erlangen program
i am not sufficiently familiar with it
to comment on it
um
let's see
uh
the um
um
yeah i should say the thing i was just
answering was about as sophisticated
technical and abstract as it comes
so aaron was asking a question here can
spoken language be broken into a set of
logical primitives what attempts have
been made to do this and so on
so
there's a question of sort of what
how is stroke spoken language structured
the first thing to say about it is it's
got a certain well it's got several
levels of structure
but one definite structure is it's got a
syntax it's got a grammar we know for
example in english
we tend to have
subject verb object
uh
you know
the uh
the cat ate the fish or something
um
we've got you know noun verb now
and we've got
uh
that so sentences tend to have this kind
of um grammatical structure
and
one can often draw out this kind of
trees where a sentence has certain
phrases you know says some
you know a collection of words that are
a noun phrase you know adjective
adjective noun let's say a collection or
a verb phrase it then goes near noun
verb noun verb noun
people i think people
kids sometimes still learn to diagram
out sentences i they didn't teach that
when i was a kid um in fact they didn't
teach any grammar except for latin which
is a somewhat simpler language than
english um and it's only only in
adulthood that i've
ended up
being exposed to the full and elaborate
grammar of english which tends to be
expressed in very thick books whereas
the grammar of latin is expressed in
much thinner books
um but any case the um so the first kind
of thing about sort of the structure of
language is it's the way that you put
words together to make sentences then
the question is what are the sentences
mean
the kind of
semantics as opposed to syntax of the
language
well
this is something where people have been
interested for a long time and can we
make computers understand english text
the question is what does it mean to
understand english text in a sense
understanding is a conversion from
something like english text to something
which is a native to the computer
understandable thing
well people hadn't really had that and i
suppose a big breakthrough that i was
responsible for back come
uh was a dozen years ago now um was what
we did in world from alpha
where and we're from alpha the idea is
you know you you give wolf now for some
input through directly on the web or
through siri or whatever else um you
give it input
uh and you ask some question
you know
what is
red blended with green i suspect that
would work
um
and uh
then
what we have to do is go from that
natural language from that english
to something which a computer can
intrinsically understand what is that
thing that a computer can intrinsically
understand
well for the last basically 40 years
i've been building this computational
language that's now our language system
which is a way of representing things in
the world computationally so what that
would turn into is something some sort
of word known to the computer blend
which is some some actual computational
word in the computational language of
language and then there would be some
representation of red and green
as as colors which are
entities understood by wolfen language
understood by our computational language
and that computational language is then
implemented actually
on computers and so then not only can
you understand that that question is you
know blend red and green but then you
can actually go and compute what's the
result of blending red and green
so in a sense the big uh one of the the
big breakthroughs of alpha was having a
very rich computational language that
could describe things about the world it
could describe things about numbers or
mathematical formulas or cities or
planets or whatever else all these
things are things that are representable
in the language and about which we can
compute things whether it's you know
cities we also have a lot of knowledge
where we know about you know the
positions and populations and so on of
cities so we can compute the distance
between two cities we're not just
looking that up where we know the
positions of the city so we can compute
that distance and if we had many cities
we could say what's the shortest tour
you can take between those cities
you first have to know the locations of
the cities and then you have to do a lot
of complicated mathematical calculation
to figure out what's the shortest path
that gets between those
okay so in any case the the sort of the
big idea there was
can one make this computational language
that represents a lot of things about
the world and yes that's what we've
succeeded in doing over the last 40
years and that's the most of what i
sort of do with my life so to speak is
gradually try to extend that
computational language try to bring
more areas of kinds of things that
people want to do and things that people
want to think about into the domain that
can be understood computationally and
that can be understood computationally
in a way that is both a good way for
humans to formulate their thoughts to
sort of click clean up their thoughts
and also a computer can actually run
these things and and help the human with
them so to speak so that's been kind of
a big big effort that uh as i say is
that much of what i spend my time doing
is building this language and gets used
by lots of people uh to do lots of
things um and although i think there's
uh uh we're still very very far ahead of
um uh of most of what we built much more
than is uh
than than than
most people know to use so to speak
but anyway the objective there is to
represent anything in the world
computationally and be able to compute
about it now one piece we haven't really
done
is what i've tended to call symbolic
discourse language
which is talking about
things just general discussion
just things like i think the example i
tend to give is you know i want to eat a
piece of chocolate
we have a great representation of a
piece of chocolate we know about all the
different kinds of chocolate we know how
big is a piece we know all kinds of
things about that we know the density of
chocolate we know all sorts of all sorts
of stuff so we can represent that but
the i want to eat part we don't have a
way to represent that yet
and so one of the things that is kind of
in my
future
development
direction
is to actually have a computational way
to represent things like i want to eat
blah blah blah
and in fact people
had people last really seriously tried
to do things like this about 400 years
ago there was sort of a
a phase when it was very popular to
think about what were called
philosophical languages which were going
to be languages that represented the
meaning of things without using words
from specific human languages it was a
time when latin was kind of going out of
circulation as the language of learning
and people were like what's next well we
can invent something that's sort of more
mathematics like that would be a
language for that could express things
sort of independent of the actual words
well there was sort of a 400 year hiatus
but we're now in a position to start
doing that again and there are many
applications for example when you have
computational contracts when you have
if you have a legal contract it's
written in human language like english
and it says various things about what
should happen and so on that what has
become important
particularly emphasized by things like
blockchain and so on
is the idea that you can have a contract
that is represented completely
computationally where where you have
something which is just a piece of
computer code effectively that says if
this happens in the world then this
should happen and so on and so on and so
on and that's something that symbolic
discourse language can potentially be
used for but anyway so so the question
then is what can you represent in in in
the world as it is
what
you're trying to represent sort of
everything in the world computationally
including things like the way we think
about things what the fact that we want
a piece of chocolate or something the
the description of our mental state
things like this
and so the question is
sort of what's involved in doing that
and what you realize is there are
certain kinds of things we know about
the world that you can encode so for
instance
uh things we've done very much you know
already in morphing language things
about
positions and positions on the earth and
and sort of spatial position and
distances and all those kinds of things
we understand that well things about
time the notion of you know you've got
uh things in the future things in the
past things that you know to accurate to
the minute things that you know accurate
to the sanctuary how that all interacts
with it with each with each other but
there's gradually different kinds of
sort of uh calculate of of understanding
of certain kinds of things which one has
to represent and that's kind of when
when i should say that i think the
question it was asked here was about
logic
sort of zooming out a little bit here
when we try to represent things that we
talk about
i think that our best hope for being
able to do that in a way that makes sort
of a bridge between us and computers is
this notion of computational language
and computational language is a very
rich way to represent things in the
world
in a form that is accessible to
computers
logic
was a particular method for doing
something a little bit like that that
was invented in the 4th century bc uh
presumably by aristotle and it's worth
understanding what aristotle actually
did
what aristotle did was he liked
cataloguing things so you know he
catalogued i know types of animals he
catalogued different causes for things
and he also looked at arguments that
people made that said things like uh
it's not true
that
either a or b
and he knew that that was equivalent to
saying
it's true oh gosh this is it's not true
that like a and b
is equivalent to
uh
i have to work this out see i'm not good
at this is is equivalent to not p or not
q is that right something like that in
any case the um there are these things
that you can say just by sort of uh you
know by making what one might call a
logical argument
that is purely a matter of for example
let's say very famous one not not p
is p
so if you say it's not
not raining today
then that means it's raining today
and that predicate
what's called the predicate it's raining
could be absolutely anything
it would be
you know it's not not sunny today means
it's sunny today and so that's a general
principle it's a general structure of
argument that the not not not something
is the same as the thing itself
a little bit of a footnote there that's
some uh
that lure of double negation is
something that is a very tricky issue in
general the the examples i've given are
rather simple examples where yes it
really works that way but uh
there's there's a whole sort of story of
whether it has to work that way
but in any case what aristotle did was
he said let's take all these kinds of
arguments that people make and let's
make an idealized version of these
arguments and represent in a way where
it doesn't matter
whether it's like uh you know whatever
it is you know pericles calling so and
so a toad or whatever or whether it's uh
you know somebody arguing for you know
the battle of salamis or whatever they
were talking about in those days um
doesn't matter what the actual subject
matter is it's just a question of the
structure of the argument and that's
what logic was intended to capture
but the way that it captured that was
very specific very much
just about these kind of straightforward
human arguments
it isn't the case that it's not obvious
that you can generalize from that to
talk about something about physics or to
talk about something about the
something about uh human
uh
emotions or something like this
it's it's a particular way of capturing
the structure of certain kinds of
arguments
now
historically the um uh
the sort of the the original structure
of logic was mostly in terms of what's
called syllogistic logic
a famous example of that is um
uh all men immortal
socrates is a man therefore socrates is
mortal that's a that's a typical example
of kind of aristotle style logic and
that got generalized and made more
mathematical particularly by a chap
called george boole in the 1830s um and
uh the um
and that led to what's called boolean
algebra which is what is kind of the the
raw material from which computers
managed to do the sort of logic that
computers do and sort of what you build
up from in a lot of things that happen
in computers
but the thing is that sort of pure logic
in the sense of ands and ors and knots
and these kinds of abstractions of
arguments that aristotle developed and
bool kind of cleaned up
um
is
that's not a good representation of
everything in the world it's a
representation of a pretty narrow set of
things in the world
and so if you say let's translate
everything in the world into logic it's
just not going to work
um and in fact we can see that
rather interestingly
in the things we've been doing now in
fundamental physics we can say where
does logic lie in this ruliad of all
possible
all possible formal systems and this and
that and the other we can say where is
logic
well logic is a little piece over in
some corner here the laws of physics
another piece over in some corner
they're not
logic is a fairly specific thing it's
not it's something which captures some
aspects of human argumentation but it
isn't some sort of universal
representation of all knowledge for
example that's just not true and it's
something actually we can see with
clarity that that's not true when we
look at these things about sort of the
way to think about fundamental physics
and the way to think about the
foundations of mathematics
so let's see
uh
um
there's a comment here
context which
um
yeah the the sort of what is language
and how to think about language yeah i'm
very interested in this question
and you know when we have a word
and
the word red let's say
that
you know i i imagine what red means
because i'm used to the fact that a
thing that is described as red
has a certain effect on the retina in my
eye and a certain you know excite
certain neurons in my brain and i call
that red
it's not obvious
that
there's
when somebody else's description i mean
something like red is a very sort of uh
there's a there's a definite kind of uh
neurological um uh representation of
that in the sense you could um but but
the question is when we have a word and
has certain meaning there's there's sort
of every use of that word has you know
this particular object is read in this
way this object is read in that way that
object is etc etc etc every instance of
the word read if we could imagine that
there was this kind of space of all
possible meanings of things
all those different uses of the word red
will be points in that space
and there's you know we could imagine
there's this huge sort of space
where as we move around the space we
move around
sort of the the the notion of meaning we
would have somewhere else in the space
would correspond to a meaning that was a
dog somewhere else would correspond to a
meaning that was something different
um and as we move around we're sort of
moving around in this meaning space but
whenever we use the word red or the word
dog we're we're sort of putting a point
in this meaning space and our different
uses of the word dog or the word red
will correspond to slightly different
points in this meaning space
and so
the the then the question is for a given
word it's sort of a cloud in meaning
space and for example if a word has many
different meanings there'll be many
pieces to this cloud and if a word
gradually changes its meaning over time
the the kind of the cloud will gradually
extend um further further out and so on
so
this is um uh
the um so so that that's that's kind of
the um
uh so then
the question of um
uh something like
how do you assign these positions in
meaning space how does that work
well we don't really know and we kind of
imagine that
the word as it is used in different
contexts
we'd sort of be able to deduce from
those contexts where that word is in
meeting space there have been attempts
to do that using machine learning that
are i would say
rather simplistic at this point um the
uh but but that's kind of the the um
uh conceptually this this notion of of
imagine a meaning space it's not clear
exactly what meaning space is
and that's something that i would like
to try to clarify
and perhaps thinking
in terms of this things like this rule
ad and so on gets very very abstract but
i think that there's a a potential way
of clarifying that um in in the perhaps
not too distant future and that will
allow us to have a more rigid version of
kind of what what it means to have you
know what these kind of clusters of
meaning are and so on
um
okay
so uh
let's see some other questions here
there's a question here very different
question from damien
uh
in the future will we have better design
and optimized cities homes everyday
objects
it's an interesting question
i i think that um
uh
you know the first question when you
talk about optimized things
is optimized for what
you know there was a so when you look at
the layout of a city for example there
are cities where
uh you know they just sort of grew up
over the course of time and people kind
of added a street here and there and etc
and they're kind of a mess
and then when cars came along for
example it was all very confusing where
do you you know where do you park the
cars how do the cars get around these
corners you know what um uh you know i
remember i i've certainly seen um
um
you know there are walled cities in
europe particularly where it's like you
can't fit a truck through the walls and
things and um you know that was they
were obviously built long before anybody
thought about trucks and thought about
that as a purpose for which you might
optimize cities
and i think
the um uh and in general
the um the sort of the structure of
cities was for a long time optimized for
people walking around or
people with horses
and then you know 100 and something
years ago cars came along and then cars
became common and then sort of
lots of things changed for example a
city which was originally something you
kind of could walk around
then there were suburbs that were tens
of miles away perhaps where yeah you
could get there just fine with a car and
that was and they were much more spread
out and so on and optimized for cars
um and you know that happened in the u.s
in the 1950s and so on that that that
sort of
growth of suburbs that um uh were kind
of
made possible by cars
and i think
then there are cities where you know
famously i don't know and it might be an
apocryphal story but but um you know the
streets of paris for example you know
napoleon made them all straight so if
things went wrong he could you know
shoot a cannon straight down the
giant city street so to speak um and um
you know that was an optimization for
something was uh sort of make the thing
straight and so on i think this question
of of um you know what does it even mean
to optimize kind of the environment we
live in so so for example another thing
is people will see some you know
classical building that has all kinds of
decoration and and uh you know elaborate
moldings and things and sort of scroll
like things on it and so on and they
might say and people did say about 100
years ago now people did say hey let's
get rid of all that stuff we're just we
don't need that it's not optimized it's
not maximally efficient we could just
have a box you know we could have all
our buildings just be be boxes
well and so then a lot of buildings got
built that was kind of a style of
architecture it's kind of minimal
geometrical style of architecture
turns out well some people like those
buildings i think i think maybe
architects like those buildings better
than the people who are in them like
those buildings sometimes um but in fact
it turns out that humans seem to rather
like having there's a certain sort of
comfort level associated with having
these kinds of things that are more
decorative and perhaps the reason for
that is because nature
is full of decoration i mean you don't
see a lot of perfect you know
you know trees that are perfect
cylinders with little spokes coming out
of them they are trees are elaborated
decorated things and so we just sort of
being out there in the world get used to
this kind of level of of kind of
complexity for free that happens in
nature and i think that's kind of why it
is more comfortable to us usually to see
things like architectural forms that
have a certain degree of nature like
decoration to them rather than being
sort of pure in a sense what you might
think of as basic mathematics you know
geometrical uh simple geometrical
structures and so on those in some sense
might be more efficient
but they are uh not as sort of uh they
don't seem to be for most people are
sort of comfortable as as things that
have more kind of structure and more
things perhaps it's like that look more
like nature and more like things we're
used to i'm not sure and so this is
again a complicated thing in
optimization of things because you know
if you waited if ever if everything you
know if you get rid of
everything in nature and you're you know
it's kind of like the people living in
the spacecraft that's going to wherever
and it's going to take a thousand years
and they're multiple generations and all
they know is the spacecraft well maybe
they would have a different
architectural sensibility about uh about
things and say no actually you know you
know when they get to the planet and
they start building a city on the on the
new planet or something they'll be like
um uh
uh you know of course we're gonna just
build these geometrical structures
because that's what we're used to so i
think it's a complicated thing to say
what makes things sort of more optimized
now similarly when it comes to things
like cities
you know we have uh there are questions
about sort of how will people get around
in cities how much do people even care
about getting around what um you know
it's been a a uh
you know to what extent is it important
to people to get around at what speed
and so on and to what extent do people
you know they're sort of paradoxical in
some sense things you might have thought
back i don't know 50 years ago or
something that you know wherever people
want to get around you want to get
around the most efficient way you can
you know then drive the car you do this
and then people realize oh my gosh if
you drive cars all the time you never
get any exercise you know much better
and much more and you don't you know you
don't produce a bunch of exhaust and so
on people are riding bicycles instead
and so what you thought was an
optimization
about make everything really good for
the cars turns out to be not quite what
you what you thought was so good and
then you're building bicycle trails and
things all over the place
and i think it's um so you know if we
look at sort of the future of cities now
there are clearly sort of coming things
you know self-driving cars uh clearly a
coming thing uh not clear how well
drones are going to play into all of
that i mean there are endless
experiments now about uh uh sort of air
taxi type things where you know because
the big thing that happened was the
possibility of that came about from from
sort of computer control of flight
together with uh uh better battery
technology made it possible to have
drones that could just be you know like
quadcopters with four four um
four propeller like things that would
just uh you know
you know do the things that drones do
and just take off vertically and and fly
around and uh you know i've seen a bunch
of demos of um no not real demos demos
of the thing on the ground
mostly yeah i think it's always been
don't think i've yeah i've seen them fly
but not with people in them right of
drones that are sort of the the air taxi
uh you know the future air taxi drone
type thing so if that worked out
then
that would again change the structure of
cities if people you know had were able
to hop from here to there
that's that changes how you need to set
up your cities
i mean it um you know there was a time
even when i was a kid
where people were saying helicopters
helicopters of the future you know and
you would see in the in the uh kind of
the predictions of the future from back
in the 1960s and so on you would see
everything flying around you know there
was everybody was flying places you know
cars were a thing of the past it's like
you know you had the the family
helicopter rather than the family car so
to speak
um and that didn't come to pass
why didn't it come to pass it's quite
subtle and quite dependent on technology
i think i think one of the main reasons
is that helicopters are expensive to
maintain difficult to fly at the time
there was no kind of possibility of
automated
controls for helicopters it was a human
kind of thing and and helicopters are
difficult to fly um they tend to be they
quite they're quite unstable in many
cases particularly in the when when
you're landing a helicopter the the you
know there's there's a time when the
when the helicopter is sort of pushed up
by air bouncing off the ground and
there's there's time when the helicopter
is is kept up by air being pushed down
from its rotor the transition between
those is complicated lots of different
things like that um so helicopters were
i think you know also that the cost of
maintaining a helicopter is very high of
you know making sure that all the parts
are
you know working correctly and so on and
so helicopters didn't catch on
and had they caught on probably cities
would be very different even today
um you know if drones catch on there'll
be a different story
if uh
that's one thing if if for example
um
sort of uh augmented reality video
conferencing kinds of things get uh
better
uh again that might change the
situations in which people will choose
to
you know even go across town to go and
see somebody such a kind of thing i mean
i think you know in this pandemic there
have certainly been some changes of
habits about the ways that people
interact and uh
you know for better or worse
but i think that you know many of those
will continue and that will probably
have an effect
but so
then there's sort of the question of uh
sometimes uh you know in cities there
have been times when it's like we've
only got a small amount of land for the
city where can we build let's build up
and so you get big skyscrapers and so on
and then you get kind of i want a better
view than everybody else maybe some of
the time you know when i was a kid
people were always talking about oh
we'll build cities in the ocean
well hasn't happened turns out nobody
really cares
um turns out that's not uh you know
that's not a a thing that we need to do
or particularly want to do
similarly people you know there have
been sort of theories where oh who needs
sunlight you know who needs this or that
will build these you know closed boxes
and so on and and that hasn't typically
worked out very well but so you know i
think
there have also been theories about how
at different times people said oh we
really want to be you know everybody
collect in the city cities are great
places to be at other times cities have
seemed like there are all kinds of
problems in cities and everybody wants
to be out of the cities it seems to vary
and it seems pretty hard to predict what
you know what you are optimizing for i
mean for example one of the things that
people
you know at different times people have
said let's make cities that just have
more room for cars and then people say
no no no you know we really like green
spaces and cities
let's make sure that there are you know
big parks and cities and so on and uh
it's it's kind of um you know goes
different different things seem to
happen at different times and i think
it's really very much a question of kind
of what people think they want
and how the evolution of what they think
they want is affected by the technology
of what's deliverable for example people
might say you know i always want to be
able to uh
oh i don't know
um
you know
let's say there's a city that's built in
a place that's that gets very cold in
the winter you know so like minneapolis
for example i think has has pretty much
you know continuous
sort of many parts of it have sort of
continuous in places where you can kind
of just walk inside without having to go
outside and that's something that's sort
of optimized for that situation
um and i think one can imagine uh sort
of other kinds of things like that that
once they're technically possible are
things that um or for example let's say
that all deliveries could be made by
drone so there are no trucks driving
around inside the city delivering things
it's all like the drone will arrive now
and and deliver it uh you know somewhere
i've seen demos of of um for uh
various companies that um i think i saw
the very first demo actually of the the
amazon delivery drone um the uh uh it's
not completely clear i don't know how
that works i mean i suppose you have a a
um there's sort of a it has to figure
out where it's going to put you know the
the package or something i don't think
it gets to to come and knock on the door
or anything um but anyway the uh maybe
maybe it calls something when it arrives
i don't know
um but but you know those are things
which will affect uh
the um
uh
will affect kind of the way that people
choose to structure things like for
example imagine that everything's being
delivered by drone
instead of like people having cat flaps
in their doors or something for cats
maybe maybe it'll become a thing that
people want to have a drone flap in
their roof that will be the place where
you know deliveries get made by the by
the arriving you know drone it's hard to
it's hard to predict those kinds of
things but i think um
uh now in terms of objects that people
have and kind of um the uh um
uh kind of the the
one of the things that that's true about
the objects we have
is
kind of
sort of as a question you can always
tell you know what's an artifact what's
a natural thing these days you can
pretty much always tell that because you
can
uh the thing that looks sort of more
geometrically simple tends to be the
object that we made
the the thing that is more sort of
elaborate will typically be the natural
object not always true i mean you can
have a perfect crystal made by nature
that's a perfect geometrical shape and
you can have some very elaborately
created industrial design that um looks
uh you know that that is quite elaborate
that humans made but the question is
will it be the case that the things that
we make continue to look sort of
understandable by us
and in a sense there's part of the um
part of the reason that that things look
understandable by us because they were
designed by us
and typically we we don't have um uh
we're not um
we're not setting things up so that we
just sort of uh do what for example
nature does and let different forms
evolve and sort of the one that is
ultimately the fittest for this
environment might succeed and so on we
tend to just say
let's sit down as an engineer or
industrial designer and sketch out what
we want this object to look like
and and so there's sort of this question
of of even if we for example were to say
okay
define a purpose
let's say the purpose we want to define
is um
what's a good example well i was going
to say design a chair but the point
about a chair is
you know it's got a human sitting in it
and so the structure of the chair is
very determined by the structure of the
human so to speak you know if we said
design a chair for a lizard well a chair
for a lizard is going to look very
different from a chair for a human but
maybe we have a different example let's
say
uh design a light fixture that will
optimally you know shine light around a
room let's say
well
you know we might think oh well we just
put an empty bulb there but oh that's
not going to work because it casts
shadows and so on we want some kind of
diffuser and we want oh we need you know
the stand for the light is going to get
in the way but we can imagine there's
sort of a different set a whole bunch of
constraints if we define we want the
pattern of light that comes out to be
have this particular form then we can
say okay computer for example go find me
the best design
out of some whole
set of all possible geometrical designs
the best shape that will lead to this
particular distribution of light and
maybe the computer will come up with
something that looks totally weird you
know has these different bulbs and
different places and they're ones
shining next to another and so on and so
on and so on and we might look at that
thing and say you know that's really
complicated right you know no human
would ever have come up with that design
but it's something that we can find in
the sort of computational universe of
possible designs we can find this
elaborate design and that's uh that's
the thing that the computer found that
was the most efficient design so to
speak
and so one of the things that i think
will probably happen is more and more of
those kinds of things where they are
sort of most given a set of constraints
the most efficient design that satisfies
those constraints is often not something
simple sometimes it's something simple
but often it's not and clearly what
matters is did you get the constraints
right let's say you define the
constraints in a computational language
then are you setting things up so that
you've got the right constraints if
you've got the right constraints now you
can design that elaborate you know uh
sort of structure to satisfy those
constraints i mean by the way you can
apply this kind of thing to lots of
different domains i mean if you've got a
certain set of constraints and you say
let's make regulations let's make laws
that achieve things with certain
constraints you can imagine you know
what's that what possible law could you
make that would you know be some
complicated thing with some taxes and
commissions and this and that that have
some elaborate structure
to achieve some particular constraint if
you get the constraint wrong
or if there's some unintended
consequence which should often will be
of the thing that you then build well
then sort of all bets are off but one of
the things that is
one of the things that i think is is the
case in the world in general
is
sort of first of all there's the process
of design which is going away from
humans and we're going to be able to
find some optimal designs that might be
things that to us humans look how would
you ever have thought of that well no
human did
and the other thing is things in the
world that we sort of interact with
through computers rather than directly
ourselves like for example if you have
some complicated set of rules about how
something should work and you know
you're buying a thing and it's it comes
with these different conditions and this
and that the other it's like if they
were fairly simple to state a human
would just say okay yeah i'll press that
button i'll get that thing but if
they're very complicated it's like well
actually you have to have a whole you
know computer figuring out oh do you do
this thing or that thing and you set
this parameter this way or that way and
so on and it's the same kind of thing in
uh well you know in a car for example in
a a
gasoline car for instance you know
you've got things where in the in early
days it's like you put your foot on the
gas and it just you know some valve
opens and you put more gas somewhere but
in today's world that's a much more
elaborate thing with fuel injection
systems and computers and it's a lot and
sensors and so on and it's something
where there isn't a kind of direct story
of kind of it was designed this way and
so it works that way there's sort of a
computer in the loop that allows the
system to work in a much more
complicated way and i think that will be
an increasing story of what happens in
the world is that it's kind of us with
our sort of general desire make the car
go faster and then it's
the sort of computer in the loop that's
doing often very elaborate things to
actually achieve the objective we want
to achieve
and i think that's some you know that
that's going to be more and more a
feature of the world that it's kind of a
world that you can sort of only uh that
has a lot of things set up that are
mediated by computer um and uh you know
i i think the fact that
there's sort of signage on roads and the
fact that we kind of you know you can
read the road sign and decide which way
to go
well they'll probably become a time when
there really aren't don't need to be any
road signs anymore because everybody has
a gps
most cars are self-driving and it's like
who needs the signage who needs all
these things saying you know turn this
way at this time it's just like just
with gps
and you know i think as sort of this
computer-mediated layer in the world
develops uh things will probably change
in terms of the way that that um uh that
things are set up i mean i remember when
i was a kid growing up in england there
was non-decimal currency which was you
know might have seemed completely crazy
because it was very hard you know some
things were convenient there were 12
pennies and a shilling and 20 shillings
and a pound and 21 shillings and a
guinea and all kinds of things like this
it was um
and you know when i was
a young kid i remember
sort of figuring out with great
excitement that money didn't have to be
non-decimal and you could actually make
money be decimal um and uh i remember
some teacher telling me it's been this
way for you know 500 years it's never
going to change and like it was only a
year later when it got announced you
know the uk is going to decimalize its
currency but one of the things i suspect
that decimalization happened in 1970.
one of the things i suspect is that had
it been delayed by another 10 years you
know electronic calculators came in 1972
had it been delayed by another 10 years
probably it never would have happened
because everybody who was like oh i
can't work out things with this
non-decimal money it's so difficult to
work with it's like don't worry about it
you've got a computer to do it you've
got a calculator to do it you don't need
to worry that it's kind of weird and
difficult to do calculations in and so
you know that's a place where sort of if
there'd been that layer that
intermediation of by computer layer in
one's interface with the world the world
could have been set up somewhat
differently and i think those are you
know those are some things that i can
see uh see being sort of happening is is
the increasing sort of computer layer um
that can
allow different kinds of things to exist
in the in the kind of raw world as as it
is um i think uh
you know in terms of of uh like
homes and what they're like you know
the the house that i have
here
we built it like 20
years ago now and there was sort of a
question at the time 20 years ago you
know what kind of home automation
should there be and what should
what should one kind of uh be ready for
in the future and i suppose my big
innovation at the time was just run
empty tubes empty conduit in the walls
because whatever kind of wires will be
necessary in the future
you know you can run them through empty
tubes
um and that has been okay except that
you know wireless technology is used for
many things although not everything and
that turned out to be a win but if you
ask you know what's fundamentally
changed i mean houses have become vastly
more complicated over the years i mean
if you look at kind of uh you know a
house from
i don't know you know a thousand years
ago or something or two thousand years
ago it's just like just the walls and
there's some openings for windows and
things and there's there's not all this
elaborate stuff in the walls and air
conditioning and and electrical uh wires
and um maybe you know fiber optic cables
and all this kind of thing i mean
there's there's a higher degree of
elaboration of what you know what it
takes to make a house and when you see a
house being built it's kind of like the
main framing of the thing can go up very
quickly but then there's all this detail
of all this stuff and insulation and
this that and the other that that has to
be put into it and one of the things
that one wonders is will that just get
more and more complicated will it
actually get simpler because there are
more things that can be kind of run it's
like oh you don't have to separately run
you know this kind of wire and that kind
of wire because they all got handled by
i mean like like you might imagine oh
i've got to run a wire for my printer or
i've got to run a wire for my this
started the other thing but actually
they're all sort of universal that they
all communicate through wi-fi or they
all communicate through fiber optics or
whatever else you don't need to have
sort of separate wires for different
kinds of things i mean it's a it's a
general trend that one sees with
computers it's like there are universal
computers that's a fundamental fact that
sort of probably i think probably the
most important scientific fact that's
emerged in the last hundred or so years
is that it is possible to have a
universal computer that you can program
to do all sorts of different things and
that idea of universality is something
that kind of
increasingly is is used elsewhere
increasingly things which used to be oh
you make a particular machine to do this
it's more you make a general purpose
machine and it can be programmed to do
all these different things
kind of brings up you know another thing
that
for well for houses for example um
you know construction
of houses is very much done by basically
by people
and um you know it's and and there's a
lot of complexity in the things that
have to be done
and you know people say well what you
know when will it come be the case that
you know you can either just manufacture
a house and uh just deliver the pieces
people have tried doing that plenty over
time but it's still not the case that
most construction is done that way or
when can you have the robots do the
construction instead it's a difficult
case for robots it's not not one of the
easier kinds of things i mean it's worth
remembering so so you know this question
about general purpose things versus
special purpose things robotics is still
pretty special purpose
i mean there are you know you end up
with a particular kind of robot arm that
does a particular kind of thing now you
can that there's some uh you know for
example to understand kind of the state
of robotics
uh this thing about can you pick up an
arbitrary object can you make a robotic
hand and whatever the shape is however
heavy the thing is however slippery it
is can you pick it up
and we humans
at least seem to be pretty good at
picking things up with our hands now of
course there's a little bit of a of a
trick to that which is the things that
exist in the world that are made tend to
be made not
you know that it's often the case that
they were made intending to be picked up
so you know we don't make a lot of
things which are like very
covered with spikes and and very
slippery and so on that we're just
really hard to pick up there's you know
the number of uses for things that are
really hard for us humans to pick up is
is is smaller and so we tend to make
things that are easier for you know our
actual hands as they're made and so on
to pick up
and so when we try and use different
kinds of materials that we might use in
a robot and we use different kinds of uh
sort of uh sensors and so on to to sense
whether you're touching things and so on
it's more difficult to um to but but
that's an example of a kind of frontline
challenge in robotics these days it's
kind of the the picking problem of you
know can you pick stuff up and it's
really hard and that's not a solved
problem yet um and so that kind of gives
you a sense of what still is to be done
in robotics and so on i think that i
i've tended to think for a long time
that eventually there will be general
purpose robotics
where you have a thing that is maybe
made from a large number of tiny
components that sort of reconfigure
themselves to be a different shape that
can achieve a different purpose
um and
once there is general purpose robotics
that will change all kinds of things
instead of
you know it'll change
certainly the construction of things
like houses and probably the cost of
constructing them it'll change uh kind
of uh it'll presumably change lots of
things about our everyday um
sort of everyday life i mean i i
remember a few years ago at being at the
annual consumer electronics show and you
know there are all kinds of wizzy things
there but the thing that was for which
there was the longest line and the most
excitement seemed to be the laundry
folding robot
which was not clear how well it worked
actually um but you know that's the kind
of thing where eventually there will be
robotic ways to do all of those kinds of
things and i think that um uh now having
said that you know i know
uh you know some kinds of sort of home
automation of you know the the different
patterns of lights that you can put on
or the elaborate uh kind of um
i i have to say maybe it's just me but
but um uh
i have not found uh you know even though
i've had sometimes even some wolfram
language based
uh sort of home automation that's been
set up i'm i've not found it as as
profoundly valuable in my life as um as
as one might have hoped and it's been
one of these areas where people sort of
say there's going to be more automation
you're going to be able to do all these
things automatically and and it's like
well yes but you know it doesn't really
matter much anyway
and it's hard to do and so on so i i'm
not sure but i think you know by the
time
by the time there's really general
purpose robotics
maybe by the time for example it's
routinely the case that a robot can put
things away for you that will be
interesting and where you know a robot
walks into room it uses kind of a visual
diff it says this is what the room
looked like yesterday this is what it
looks like today oh i can see this you
know these visual changes to what's
happened you know and it kind of brings
up and your thing you know do you want
to put this away now you know you took
this book out from here do you want to
put that book away um back where it came
from so to speak that's the kind of
thing where we don't yet have that
capability but we presumably will and
that will probably change
and you know maybe there's the question
of of again we've optimized kind of uh
well like for instance you know i've had
a bunch of these robotic vacuum cleaners
for ages and um i suppose some changes
uh you know made some changes because
it's like well this piece of furniture
the thing is always going to get stuck
there so let's change that
and um
you know one can imagine that uh just
like in designing cities if there's a
different form of transportation you end
up designing things differently um so
similarly with houses if you know if
it's really important that the um uh you
know the the floor robot or whatever can
get from here to there and it's really
pretty easy to remove that that strange
mat that it always gets stuck on or to
you know to build this little extra you
know the robot flap or something then
then people will end up doing that
all right um
maybe one more
uh
one more thing or somebody's commenting
here
um
that uh since the world is now built
around humans would humanoid robots be
the most general
that's that's an interesting issue i
mean i think
that
uh
that's it is certainly true that if you
build a walking
you know
robot that's you know five or six feet
tall and has hands and arms and so on
yeah the world has been built for things
like that
and so for some purposes of robotics
that will be the best form factor um i
mean you know but of course there are
things robots can do like you could have
a little drone flying robots that goes
and you know goes and does that thing
about checking whether anything needs to
be put away in your house you know it
could be the the the uh the robot that
is optimized with many arms and the
thing that has a has something that can
sort of uh uh put itself up you know to
to reach that highest bookshelf so to
speak which a human would have a hard
time with and you have to get a ladder
and this and that and the other you know
you could imagine a robot that has these
optimized you know uh legs that just
extend up to be able to reach that not
very humanoid like and where you know
where you can imagine the sort of
symbiosis of the little you know drone
flying robot that flies around your
house and finds what needs to be put
away and then the robot that is you know
all arms or something that uh goes in in
a better way puts things away but yes in
terms of sort of the general purpose
robot that is in the built environment
that is you know houses and cities and
things like that it's very likely to be
the case that something which is sort of
humanoid in form is going to have an
easier time navigating
that term
uh that environment now of course if
it's like okay robot go out in the
jungle or go out in uh you know under
water or something like that well those
are not human built environments and so
a completely different form factor and
structure might be the optimal one but
yeah it's a it is a it's a funny thing
that once
technology gets built in a certain way
it tends to be the case that a lot gets
built on top of the often rather
arbitrary decisions that were made in
setting up the technology in the way
that it was set up i mean you know once
a certain piece of infrastructure is in
place in some form
lots of things get built on that even if
it was kind of a weird um uh you know
even if it's it's almost sort of a a a
weird thing that you would you would
construct that way
um
well what's lots more to say here about
um
the um
yeah i mean obviously there's there's a
lot of interesting questions about
future technology and robots and um you
know what happens when you have the home
robot and you have all these ethical
decisions you know should the home robot
move the cat
if the cat was having was sleeping
happily what are the conditions for
moving the cat when is it ethical to
have the robot you know sort of
push the cat into some corner when is it
um you know and what what cat rights
does the cat should the cat have
relative to this or that and those are
things which you know particularly if if
you leave
you know robot and cat home alone you
know what does the um uh what autonomous
decisions should the robot make um about
what to do or you know in um uh you know
they're just endless uh well of course
that that comes up even more it hasn't
hasn't really come to pass yet but but i
think it will come to pass with with old
folk before it comes to pass with young
kids of the the you know the robot that
takes care of the person so to speak and
what its uh kind of principles are in
terms of what it should do and not do
and so on and under what circumstances
it's kind of like the the famous
question of uh uh you know when you when
you ask the self-driving car to drive
above the speed limit what should it do
and um under what circumstances you know
and and what does the what does the law
say about that well it usually says you
know
if you if you need to go about the speed
limit for a really good reason you can
do it
um but uh uh and you know how does the
self-driving car assess was it a really
good reason you know oh to avoid an
accident oh to do this or that um and
you know the way that these things are
set up now it's very much well if the
human thought this
even if the human was wrong it's okay
but and then
when it's a kind of an ai system how
does that uh
how does one decide whether it was
reasonable for it to have thought that
and so on
all right well lots of interesting
questions and and things
to discuss there so we've gone from the
atoms of space
to uh cat-moving robots
um and uh well hope people found this
interesting you know i always
find these fun because uh you'll get me
to think about things that i don't
normally think about and it's kind of a
great exercise for for my brain at least
of um
of thinking about all these different
kinds of things and
the connections between them so please
uh
feel free to
to suggest topics ask questions i on our
uh the form that we have out there and
um
look forward to being with you another
time
so thanks very much